Discrete mathematics. It really is your gateway.
to the most
amazing and
intelligent ideas
in mathematics
this is a
topic you really want to invest.
time
and effort in
it will pay off.
Greatly in your career software engineer
or data scientist, or you may
be an engineer.
I mean in any aspect.
Of our world where mathematics is applicable.
And should you want to be proficient in that particular?
field of work
discrete mathematics. Well really take you
far.
But let me draw your attention now here to the slide.
I told you that discrete mathematics is a subset
of pure mathematics and if I were to classify discrete
mathematics in my classification is based on what I've seen.
In books on discrete mathematics. Well, it will be
most of what
You would find the computer mathematics excluding complex
numbers and Analysis. Why because these two
particular topics are concerned with
well not discrete things.
And to say something is this good is
to say that it is whole.
It is.
not
continuous
a number that a number that
has whole is something like
an integer
it is not there is no decimal involved.
There are no fractions involved.
All right.
now let's talk about algorithms logic and
prop propositional calculus now logic is
about
deductive reasoning
it is about going from a set of premises.
a set of statements
and then arriving at one conclusive.
statement
and
to perform such an operation where
we go from a set of premises or a set
of arguments.
to some conclusive
statement
you will perform some sort of calculus on
these premises.
That is what propositional calculus is.
It is about.
dividing your arguments into statements
and then performing
calculations on them like you would in
algebra, although the rules here are different and the
operations that you perform on these premises are
different.
But again, it's not something.
difficult to do with it something that is very
natural to us as human beings.
logic, that is
and if
Pride programming before and you've come across FNL statements.
And you probably know how that they're quite easy.
Assuming you already familiar with this attacks and you know,
they're pretty easy to implement.
Of course, there will be situations where
you're not doing
a small number of logical operations
It can it it can get quite elaborate but
it is.
important
for proofs
if you want to be able to
like I said read and even write
your own proofs.
and propositional calculus
is
a necessity
But when it comes to applications and computer science or
even data science.
logic
Is at the heart of art well Machine learning.
It is at the heart of you know.
Game Theory
And game one of the applications of game theories for
example how to set up rules.
to prevent fraud
or to cruise, excuse me to increase
customer acquisition or to prevent
customer attrition or employee attrition
It is used in natural language processing. So
I'm sure we've all.
If you use Gmail.
And you're trying to write settings and you find the Gmail completes the
sentence for you.
Or when you are texting.
and
the
operating system is able to correct your
text still sometimes they make mistakes, of course, but usually they
they get it right. Well like in
all of these examples.
propositional calculus
is at the center the programming implementation
of ideas and problems proposition calculus
are implemented.
So
so we will shortly switch to switch to the tutorial and
talk about this.
but
here's where proposition calculus is directly
applicable with respect to algorithms.